oh hi it's shooter week here on Game
life and I I don't know anything about
those games at all I just play wii music
pretty much so we got Nate Ralph right
here who has been playing gears of war
two and resistance two and he is going
to tell us which is the better shooter
for your holiday dollar yeah alright
resistance to so resistant who kicks off
with the story of Nathan Hale it's right
after the first game ends he's been
affected by this chimera buyers who is
essentially a super soldier they haul
him back to Iceland where a bunch of
scientists are working on sort of
controlling this infection so he doesn't
get converted completely two years
passed and there's an entire team of
them now so there are four guys they're
called sentinels and they're gearing up
to pretty much take on the Chimera when
the US gets invaded easily I like a fly
over to Idaho of all places and take
them off alright so sentinels crazy all
kinds of stuff going on whatever how's
it play well the action it's pretty much
an amped-up first-person shooter it
doesn't really do anything especially in
New but it does everything really really
well within the first five minutes of
game you're taking down your very first
gigantic monster machine you know this
the sort of the action never ever really
stops which can be a good thing and the
weapons insomniac they made rattling
hunt the weapons are really inventive
really creative you know you've got
weapons like the auger rifle which you
know shoots blast of radiation for the
walls you've got the bull's eye which
you can you know shoot a homing tag in
an enemy and
all the bullets follow the enemy and
then we've got new weapons like the
spider grenade and like spreads poison
gas then light on fire and if you're in
the way up everyone's gonna die you know
sort of like lots of new inventive
weapons the enemies require a little bit
of maneuvering around them because there
are so many of them there are hordes of
them and they're all really fast they go
down pretty easy but there are tons of
them you're running out of ammo your
scrounging around for new weapons you've
got to rely on cover but there's no
cover system really so that's kind of a
pain you know you're ducking behind
columns in terms of that the campaign
itself is a lot of fun there's no co-op
to the campaign there's no copy of
single-player campaign rather which is a
really big sticker with me because I
played resistance one with a bunch of
friends co-op oh so I actually removed
actually the name that the coop from
that particular campaign ok ok another
co-op mode but I say no so overall it
really seems like you enjoyed resistance
to hide I would love his family original
resistance and resistance to just
improve everything alright and just
takes it to the next level ok so moving
right along you also play through gears
of war tonight did play kids avoid Gears
of War is a great game the problem is
it's sort of like I mean no one really
plays Gears of War for the store there
again for burly alpha males they're
charged with you know defending the
entire human race because wave after
wave of it also just really don't amount
to much of anything you need these you
know Marcus Fenix and Coltrane whose
character I just absolutely hate ok are
just a series of art types they're great
characters but they're all know sort of
established art types that aren't really
developed at all you know they're all
Angry they're all huge and muscular and
the game is visceral it's great it's a
really fun sort of like game and just
sit down co-op again brilliant and you
sit down with your friend and you're
just hacking through people with
chainsaws and blowing them up with all
sorts of with grenades unchanged a lot
of fun to play through so here's your's
too does have a co-op campaign does that
that's the game you want to sit and play
with your if you want to play with a
buddy online or offline yes
the way to do it play through the entire
single cam single-player campaign and
it's a whole lot of fun the problem is
there's no depth to it it's like a an
adolescence you know fairy tale there's
even a love story that reads like fan
fiction it's like you know so how's the
action the action is great the cover
system is absolutely fantastic and
they've actually improved it with gears
two it's a lot more fluid you know
running from Ellen that one animal
element to the NEX it works well the
problem is they're really it hasn't
really developed at all it's just it's
great it's fun it's just there's no
depth to it you know I'm not 15 anymore
I'm allowed to have hobbies that are a
little less shallow mmm okay okay no now
years to actually does have some really
interesting multiplayer modes like
there's the horde mode right the horde
mode is it's great again it's a team a
team of players fighting wave after wave
of enemies they get significantly harder
it's it's great but there's not much to
it so all right I'm starting to get a
sense of maybe where you where you stand
on this but okay you know in the the
shooter Wars of 2008 which wich game
reign supreme bearing in mind that
resistance to is exclusive to the
PlayStation 3 years of war 2 is
exclusive the xbox 360 so you're gonna
be pissing off a whole lot of fanboys no
matter why hey really going to get a
death threats which is the best game I
can't win this either way as a
disclaimer I'm a PC gamer so I I have no
no particular bet in this console water
you're not biased resistance resistance
to is the way to go it's an evolution
over the original resistance it's
they've changed the game completely
they've improved upon an already great
experience it's got a brilliant story a
brilliant environment brilliant world
it's not perfect but there's a lot of
progress there and it's a great game
gears two is also a great game it's also
just gears one with a bit more scenery
and a love story if you know that sort
of thing and of course they're very
different very different case so just
play the one that you want to play but
resistance to but resistance is the
better one win this round Sony he said
so